unas protestas en contra del olvido que
terminaron con enfrentamientos entre los
manifestantes y la policía miles de
personas marcharon en diferentes partes
del territorio chileno para conmemorar
el estallido social que se extendió por
el país en octubre de 2019 y que dejó
decenas de muertes y cientos de heridos
entre los reclamos justicia para las
víctimas de la violencia policial y
reformas al sistema educativo pensional
y sanitario segunda vez que bajamos a
esta situación estamos luchando por lo
mismo
no es posible que nuestro pueblo esté
dormidos
en total 50 manifestaciones fueron
convocadas en todo chile motivadas por
la desigualdad social en un país donde
el 1 por ciento de los hogares de
mayores ingresos acaparan más de una
cuarta parte de la riqueza nacional la
conmemoración se da en un momento clave
en el rumbo del país a un mes de las
elecciones presidenciales en donde el
candidato del oficialismo solo tiene una
intención de voto del 7% y el mismo día
en que se desarrolló el primer debate de
la convención encargada de redactar la
nueva constitución chilena uno de los
grandes logros de las protestas del 2019
dejando atrás la anterior carta magna-
instaurada durante la dictadura de
augusto pinochet me parece que también
la ciudadanía está poniendo su
expectativa su confianza en que este
nuevo texto refleje lo que fue el 18 de
octubre
de 2019 entonces creo que esta segunda
conmemoración y en esto creo que los
convencionales constituyentes tuvieron
una gran visión de resignificar el 18 de
octubre ahora con una construcción no
solo como con el quiebre no solo con las
revueltas se espera que la constitución
estilista en marzo del próximo año y que
pueda contribuir a subsanar los reclamos
de un movimiento que aún hoy sigue
latente